il 20 ragazzi che sta vibrando estero
ciao ciao ciao uomo codino anno ma sei
una donna ciao donna che insieme sono
una donna
sei una donna si tu sei nero ma cosa
sono nero sei razzista lo prendo come un
complimento vuol dire che c'è la mazza
siamo contrari al power oppure meglio
dire salvatore ciao a tutti mi chiamo
salvatore cinquegrano e sono una donna o
le bocce ne vado fiero sì esatto che ora
di farti notare una cosa siamo subisce
la clean up dove i secchi sono l'essenza
della vita perché non riusciamo mai a
pulire e qualche dell'acqua a che figata
è vero infinita quest'acqua c'è un ninja
che serata la passa gioia oddio nostri
fermo fermo con la roma che fai male fai
male non ti preoccupare vai via ti sfido
a duello vai video o un goccio con cosa
vuoi che combatta vai via
basta a maggio contro catania non vale a
il suicidio
comunque non ho capito natio rai che
cos'è sta roba un tempio dove si sognava
da bug o da una pagoda sono dati mazzate
madonna che risalgono però questo è un
figo sopra e vabbè come morto questo
scusa non volevo giuro voglio vedere
quanto facciamo qua sarà incasinati non
però non lo so ci siamo ragazzi surreal
power fa vj ditta di pulizie chiamato
siamo i raccoglitori i re pulitori
perché le apriamo mentre chiudiamo
esatto io am see surdi from japan mangio
sushi anche
sven bravo vigna che rapper questo flo
voglio 60.000 live è il nostro nuovo
album ragazzi o vorrei mano motion è una
24 ore con dentro i soldi il big money
di lava grava tutto gravi al iv v e di
vincere ti lanci soldi addosso i big
money di youtube è la madonna persona
amica la mazzetta proprio da mille
rinnovabile qualche [ __ ] ricco reich
e condividi le cose la mancia che danno
all'impresa di pulizie esare ovviamente
c'è talmente tanto schifo che non
potranno andare la mancia guarda ecco la
mancia grazie e vabbè il sangue sul
tappeto rosso in guardo non lo vedi
quindi di un tipo io in casa cioè il
parquet quando devo dire un cazzo perché
lo stile dello sport coni cagli per
terra insomma diciamo che dopo io prendo
le così gialli che come noi mettiamo
dentro i cadaveri
ho capito che sono giapponesi ma dire
cosi gialli cosi gialli e razzini equa
allora questa è la sostanza la mia è
tutta pulita
c'è anche il secondo piano no l'ho già
fatto e stavano di non farti vedere una
cosa ok ti prendo a schiaffi con la mano
del buddha osserva perché hai trovato la
mano del budda non solo vedere vedere
fermo belli ha fatto anche il rumore del
buddha vorrei capire chi aveva dei pezzi
così grossi del coe va beh mi è un
gigante incinta
ok centrato stato brado abbiano che voi
sporchi tuo che l'effetto dove sei io
sono qua che sto cercando di mettere le
cose di cadaveri dentro il secchio
perché alla fine dovremmo buttare tutti
insieme mazzette sporchi di sangue le
vuoi
no sono soldi sporchi
cioè tutto no mai saltato un pezzo del
vecchio dice soldi ma poi si brucia
anche il coso giallo ci metti lisce e
dentro ho trovato un fegato su pokemon
gol ma crore pokémon gol subisce la
simulata guarda c'è un pikachu sul mio
cadavere
ma è questo lo vado a buttare che pieno
aspetta aspetta aspetta giosa ancora con
il solito ok dove vince chi sa parli
genitore che qua ma perché ogni volta è
perché voi magari si è bruciato in
fretta
ok pulisci le mani per favore subito ce
l'ho qui non si puliscono un cuore lo
vuoi un quali ti serve un cuore
no grazie sono abbastanza freddo di li
metti immagine passo pd fanno anche la
differenziata
9 della carta voglia prendi la carta la
punti li larga e questo tutto organico
come è anche quelle vere dove rispettare
tutto nell'unico tendono anche o sport
quanto sono stupido la mia madre mi
diceva di dare una mano di smetta di
giocare videogiochi dare una mano in
casa vedi che roba sta facendo che ios
padana mentre la del secchia aspetta
sono i problemi di spazio
lol recavano al giorno a regà bongiorno
a spada dentro orca eva non entra dentro
un cazzo è vero ma girarla gira la
picchia tipo in verticale per fosse
entrare forse no penso allora senti
porca eva hai ragione da gioco gira la
ne vai così non c'era anche a quattro
che squadra alcuno la z come non alterna
come la lanterna un neon sì ma la
buttiamo teniamo davvero rabbia ecco
bravo così almeno vediamo le chiazze di
sangue dove non si vede è che buona cosa
la csi dobbiamo buttare i cestini quindi
prendiamo i cestini per buttare i
cestini esatto cestino nei cestini cesti
actions pecca mettiamo cestino nel
cestino
bravo esatto the fall
no mi sono usciti nel calda dai che non
di cadaveri
sì dalla [ __ ] lo speriamo
grandissimo canestro al volo è vero
aspetta aspetta a fermo così chiedilo in
aria
no era più forte più forte ho mischiato
cestista ragazzi che cestista magic
johnson tutto lui questo fujiwara come
contento di essere morto sto tizio ora
bilancio questa e benzina
no 262 vagliati cercata gradi 9 e
raggiunto queste benzina la cosa che
suicidio e da da 3 metri ecco le ssis
infatti una gamba ma se uno si butta da
3 metri li che cazzo succede da 39 a tre
beni o ti fai niente anche se sicuro
vogliamo provare domani problemi dove
troviamo ora chi veramente abbiamo
pulito tutto incredibile sono commosso e
con questo dovremmo aver sterminato
che cosa le scale o dato fondo alle
scale magari fuoco ho preso una lanterna
si è esplosa la lanterna aspetta che la
morisco io si vuole che si incide rito
tutto si 6 incenerito tutto per terra ci
credo perché qua tutto di legno pre
tuttofuoco troppo ferito con la pagoda
ora mi impicco mica un film ripulirà re
dopo anni ok faccio un giro al piano di
sopra per vedere se ha posto anche più
di sopra poi basta abbia finto detto al
mio no ci sono dei mitra qua e basta da
un secchio bravo al piano di sopra del
secondo l'alta salta grande madonna che
gioco di squadra nè preso no ora non lo
prende lo prende lascialo a yara si sia
buttata che tentiamo i proiettili
buttiamo insomma perché faccio tutto il
rumore
non lo so infatti adesso mi butterò giù
ma accadrà tutto è semplice che cazzo
dov'è il genitore ballare io l'onore di
buttare l'ultima cosa vai buttane dopo
anni migliore ho sbagliato a non che è
giusto più giù di lì
ciò che c'è proiettile apri apri le
prime a [ __ ] va a posto
una vita che vogliamo finito tutto
pulito non ci si può credere fischer ha
completato assurdo andiamo al computer
ma se forse esce fuori che abbiamo fatto
qualcosa tipo 99 per 100 min park tra
diavoli lecce 26 possibile dovesse
cliccare il secondo in teoria i'm proud
of my performance ok ok il napoletano di
office non è concluso trovò style
promossi 6 97 per cento cosa cosa 97 per
cento cose ma cosa c'era di più ma
[ __ ] ci ho visto 40 minuti e 40
minuti per fare ancora e siamo in due
per fare il 97 per ragazzi risultato più
vicino alla perfezione di vincerà mai il
mio sono andate così erano quei 3 per
cento che manderà socio preventivamente
a borghetto casco sarà mica il tuo caso
che devo pulire no ma credo anche il tuo
ego archive a 96 grazie grazie per mia
madre 97.000 likely vale 97.000 live
97.000 lei per il 97 per cento dobbiamo
arrivarci si arrivava a 100.000 ne
faremo un altro con 100 per cento si
spesa bio in in 16 però che io sono
soddisfatto contento felice e va bene
quindi di ragazzi se ho un sacchi come
se avessimo pulito davvero un tempio
gigantesco parola vuota
spero che questo tutorial sul b della
cinepresa lino vi sia per questo è
dell'avanzo e niente gli adesso infilerò
questa spatola nel deretano di surreal
power bossi come piace a me
si crede ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto spero che vi siate divertiti a
vederci pulire le cose poi si volta
facciamo un gameplay su luglio che mi
rimetto a posto la camera dei ragazzi
spero che mi sia piaciuto consente se mi
piaci tu argomento è un mi piace passate
anche incarichi suri provvedere
l'episodio con lui che sempre subisce al
simulator dove abbiamo fatto esino tifo
e niente sono stati siete ci vediamo al
prossimo video per
anche al telecomando che qua e d'aria
[Musica]